if it was five rounds I think just in
case you could be in some trouble three
rounds I think he has the toughness to
get through it uh wouldn't be surprised
if gaichi won never surprised if gaichi
wins it's just a very tough technical
fight for him you're talking about a guy
in physive who's more technical quicker
not as many fight miles even though
they're similar in age gaichi's
wrestling and the way his fighting style
you know it catches up with you fast so
by all accounts this is not a great
fight for Justin gaichi exciting fight
Battle of the nose jobs let's see whose
nose is going to hold up I would assume
both their noses get broken in this
fight perceives a minus 225 for a reason